رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه مصمم على وضع حد
لازمه اللاجئين غير الشرعيين في بريطانيا
حيث من المتوقع ان تصدر حكومه حزب
المحافظين مشروع قانون يوضح كيفيه التعامل
مع القوارب غير الشرعيه التي تمر عبر
القناه الانجليزيه ولكن هناك العديد من
الانتقادات التي تواجه مشروع القانون هذا
الذي يوصف بانه قاسي حتى قبل صدوره مثلا
من داخل حزب المحافظين الذين يرون بان
الشوناك ربما يغامر بمنحه وعودا كبيره دون
الالتفات الى الجانب الانساني لطالبي
اللجوء كما انهم يعتبرون ان مشروع القانون
هذا لن ينجح دون مشاركه فعاله وجديه من
فرنسا حزب المعارضين حزب العمال يرى بان
مشروع القانون هذا غير قابل للتطبيق وبانه
ربما تكتيك سياسي قبيل انتخابات مايو 2024
طبعا ازمه اللاجئين غير الشرعيين ازمه
ليست جديده على بريطانيا
ولكن المعطيات السياسيه هي التي تغيرت
هناك حكومه جديده تريد اتبعت نفسها هناك
اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين الذين وصلوا الى
بريطانيا خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
ولكن الاهم ربما ان بريطانيا تريد ان تثبت
انها قادره على السيطره على حدودها رغم
وعيوبه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه